oh my gosh I love this floral fit okay
how do we get in and out of this is this
all one piece right here
all yeah I was like once I'm in this
you're in it like nothing I can do
nothing and then I thought did they make
this for me because how does it fit
perfectly like literally the actual
fingers the shoes anyways you are in it
to win him and I'm probably gonna win
guys I don't mean to say that but come
on Justin is incredible I'm supposed to
ask you how confident you are that you
might beat the boys this season girl you
are really confident honestly I it
doesn't even obviously matter because
everybody is so good that's left it's
it's the first time I'm really like I
don't know tonight what's gonna happen
like only four people can go through
there's gonna be four singing for their
lives and then one goes through so
um even if Justin does end up singing
for his life I feel super confident that
he will go through he's one I think he
has so many fans out there just because
of him his personality and just his
heart is so big and
um that that's not even talking about
his singing is that you know and it's
not even just the singing but it's it's
just the heart that he puts behind the
singing so I just feel honored to work
with him I just finally started DM like
dming with him like the other night this
weekend we were talking about songs and
he sent a song to me that
um literally triggered like so many
emotions like it's super unexpected song
for him to do that he wants to do and I
listened to it and I was like oh my gosh
I was literally in tears listening um
just like a personal thing so it's just
been a really amazing season Too Short
it's mine of like last last it's mine
and Blake's last season let me say that
again because I can't even get the words
out of my mouth because it sucks you
your eyes are watering this is you know
what's so funny is we have had many
interviews on this voice record but I
have said those words to you before your
eyes are watery whatever you talk about
Blake in this capacity you get emotions
it's like you know this is a show that I
never in my lifetime would picture me
doing something like this it's been one
of the most fun things I've ever done I
love being a coach I love watching the
contestants grow I love having an impact
you know super inspiring for me and then
on top of it I meet like my best friend
here that's gonna be like forever mine
and there's a lot of like Nostalgia
going on so there's a lot of emotion on
this carpet you shared a sweet moment
with Camila when she first arrived you
called her your daughter now worst case
scenario Justin goes home this week
which other coach are you pulling for
husband or daughter well I have a lot of
people that I'm I'm fans of but I would
say Bodhi is um I think he's incredible
I really do because I feel like
for my taste I he can he has like this
really skillful voice but he's also such
an artist like alternative artist and
um you could just tell he's just a very
unique person so maybe I would maybe him
but I like Brayden I like I there's
somebody everybody that's left I love
they're all incredible we gotta get a
win for the household Let's Do It come
on I will say though of course then you
have Camila's singer and these are so
much talent everywhere and she and I
were just talking because I asked what
would it take to get a Gwen Camila
collaboration and she's down she says
she wants it to be like an Fu Anthem and
she called you a Trailblazer I mean like
we need this dynamic duo well listen
anything look it I'm proof Anything Can
Happen look at all the crazy stuff
that's happened so far
um I've really enjoyed working with
Camila she's a funny girl she came over
her and John came over for dinner on
Friday night we had like a little coach
dinner we've never done that before but
I was like Blake we have to fit it in
like we have to do it this is our last
season we want to have that memory so we
did it it was really fun and um I'm
gonna miss her you know she does not
live in LA she makes that very clear
she's a Miami girl
um look at her oh my God and she's so
cute tonight she looks so cute I love
that you and Blake have taken over the
host Reigns because usually John and
Chrissy do the coach dinner so yeah
who's the better cook in the kitchen for
you cooking something very big right now
I don't think she really has the energy
she's at the end of that difference yeah
um honestly we had a chef come this time
and um that's we don't do that very
often but there's this Italian chef that
we had come a few weeks go and I was
like let's get that guy to come it was
really fun it was fancy and cute and
yummy and um I think the thing is is
that you just at this time of year
hardly have time to do anything and I
was like let's make this happen so it
was really fun and plus with covid we
just stopped doing that kind of stuff
you know we have to start getting into
this like having people over and we love
hosting yeah we love it so your house is
the place to be for the holidays this
season for sure and you know what we do
host a lot we just it's mostly we have
such a big family it's always family
stuff like okay you know 30 people
coming for Thanksgiving let's go and
there is no Chef we are we are the cooks
so who's who's the better cook you or
Blake
um I would say
um I'm not that good I would say that
I'm good at certain things and he makes
me like he's it's great when we're
together because he'll like read recipes
and like make sure that I measure
correctly because all I get distracted
you know what I mean but he's actually
really has a lot of intuition about
cooking like he Seasons really well and
he's a really good fryer
um fancy bag He's Country baby
and me by the way never even grew like
fried that word is a sin so I don't know
[Music]